please welcome ryan kyra armstrong
[Applause]
oh my goodness i'm not able to keep it
together i'm so happy to meet you
i watched the film and it's so good
you're so good at it oh my god
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it's so good you're so amazing in it
what have you got in your hands so i
have
this drawing for you
um because how amazing you are and here
it is oh my god
um so since there's so many close-ups of
like eyes throughout both of the fire
starters our two fire starters there's
so many close-ups so i figured i would
draw one for you and clearly we all
equal awesomeness so
[Applause]
i mean full blown framer on wall forever
in nearest spot that i look at every day
of my life please sit down
um
i um is it is it true that like you did
something for school and et am i getting
this right
so yes right before i was actually ever
an actor i was i think i think i was
like six seven years old and it was
dress up as your inspiration day like
dress up as whoever inspires you
and so
um
i ended up dressing us up as you
when you're in e.t
and so now that i'm here it's insane
and um
this is crazy
but then
i got to do fire starter and yes it
changed one is like love everybody and
the other is i will blow you up oh yes
if you mess with me and my family
it was um probably the most empowering
thing that ever could have happened to
me what was the experience like for you
because it really changed my personality
oh yes it i also i love like beforehand
i like
okay sorry i just cannot speak right now
so i'd also love the fact like she has
super powers right so she's like this
this character with super hours and like
i go to the movie theaters i watch like
super power movies all the time so this
is like crazy first of all and then when
i'm on set i just like feel like this
empowerment of like
back away or this this will all happen
to you and so it was honestly so cool
and like i love seeing the effects as
well because i got to see like all the
stuns it's so cool there are not a lot
of us young girls out there who have
the super powers and i don't know why
that's not a more tapped into market i
would love to see young girls kick and
butt honestly yes
i agree
and
but i'm i'm so glad that we're so lucky
that these moments or opportunities have
been reserved for these
incredible fortunes that we've gotten to
learn about ourselves work hard and
bring out characters and films that like
speak to people because they are unique
they are definitely unique um look oh my
gosh
that is just so crazy it is crazy
will you come here with me oh sorry oh
god stuck on skirt yeah i was seven then
i'm 47 now can you believe that that was
40 years ago
you're tall
it's these shoes oh my gosh these shoes
i had to actually practice walking in
these because i was just like
here i'll just
i love the socks i really do yeah this
is my socks
there we go now we're the exact same
height yes oh my gosh
40 years
and it is just an honor
to be in this
[Applause]
now
i was so excited to see that the iconic
poster
from stephen king's novel to back in the
day when we made it
um they're all
they're all
having an empowered symmetry of likeness
which i think is so cool
um so uh do you want to recreate it with
me as we go to break i would love all
right here we go ready let's do it okay
[Applause]
[Music]
you